two contestants won a professional chef
one just regular all guy will compete to
make the best sandwich possible with the
same ingredients this is sandwich
showdown
I have Marty Nassif and I've been a
professional chef for the past five
years it's up from Jordan a big fan of
sandwiches my favorite type of food to
make is quickly Italian food
I'm a terrible cook and a very lazy cook
I believe in kitchen sink ism if it's
good throw it in there anything that's
good is gonna be good together I think
I'm gonna win because I know sandwiches
and I'm probably the best at them
Marty's going down the contestants will
have to make the best sandwich possible
with the provided ingredients
[Music]
the showdown starts now see to the
jalapenos I'm gonna try to make some
sort of spread for this bread right here
lay men might ignore the panini press
but as a sandwich expert I know that
that's probably the most important part
gonna butter all the bread put the bread
face down and panini that [ __ ] thank you
guys so much super simple because I
think simple sandwiches are better than
some more complex sandwiches yeah I
think I'm just gonna put everything in I
have a signature sandwich at BuzzFeed
apples melted mozzarella sticks hot
cheetos and honey I used like half a
stick that's gonna go up with the
cheddar
[Music]
sometimes you got a little mustard baked
into the buttery flavor so I'm just
gonna have a little slight amount of
mustard
I think it's better if you don't get too
much or like when you're taking a bite
out of this bread and you pull the rest
of the cheese out kind of sucks
see how that mustard see you know right
there that's all the lettuce you need
for one sandwich
tomate simplicity is everything you have
to break along the curve so that they
like flatter in the sandwich I don't
know what it means that I do everything
in like even numbers know this what's up
it's just a simple sandwich you always
got to have a custom sauce in your
sandwich competition lots of balsamic a
little bit of mustard a little bit of
mayonnaise just a splash of sriracha
into butter to make the whole thing go
down smooth together right there it's a
huge sandwich and that's how you make a
sandwich let's see how the judges feel
about this masterpiece
I'm YB I don't like sandwiches but I
like food so I'm excited to try them hey
I'm Ryan I've had mini a sandwich let's
see what you got I'm Keith in the video
let's do this I'm already tell us about
your sandwich this is called the happy
turkey sandwich basically created a
jalapeno Mayo get a great mouthfeel
precision yeah good sandwich equilibrium
the cheese is great I'm getting a lot of
the cheese I'm not sure if I'm getting
enough for the turkey just because the
cheese is like got a nice wall around
the turkey the cheese is overpowering a
little bit but I love cheese and
honestly I could go for a little thicker
slice on this tomato but I do appreciate
the thin slice I think it's neat I think
most people don't want to tell you
tonight I think presentation was great I
think the precision of the cuts were
phenomenal
I also love to have a stack so
colorfully this is more of a cheese
sandwich a turkey sandwich I think the
amount of it we need to put in balance
out the bread really well I was actually
a little bit worried that I might have
lost to amateur Jordyn tell us about
your sandwich this sandwich is called
sink the subject I'm a strong believer
in kitchen sink ISM wherein you throw in
everything but the kitchen sink mine it
has a tongue sticking out of it it's
very wet on the bottom uh-huh
okay not gonna lie looking at I was like
this is gonna be disgusting but all
right after a bite you put it in breasts
yeah I'm surprised at how tasty it is it
it tastes like lots of sauces I think
there's way too many pickles on this I
ended up eating everything separately
though like it was like never all at
once
it tastes flying a perfect drunken
sandwich I overdid it with some of my
ingredients I'll be the fourth to admit
it gentlemen you both created some
excellent sandwiches today and we
commend you for your work but now it is
time for us to pick a winner whose
sandwich reigns supreme
why be
I'm gonna go with the happy turkey I
think I'm gonna go with sink the subject
both sandwiches were really great
Jordan I think you did a great job and
you're saying way to that great flavors
but you could never sell that sandwich
and therefore I have to go with the
happy turkey congratulations your
sandwich reigns supreme it felt great to
win I didn't know that I was going to
because I said I'd probably make a
better sandwich and I did he was a
master of restraint which is something
that I am NOT Jordan is very creative
but he let his imagination get the best
of him I hope that one day like Marty's
my sandwiches will be less slippy and
more spiffy
[Music]